hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
this is my sister actual real-life
sister Jenna sure oh hi they always are
like what's a sorority sisters no no
same shirt on on accident we also I got
this too I ordered this before I even
know that you got the same shirt I
bought us little Easter I feel better
yes what is that wait look good oh look
you can put this on our little but we're
not doing that we got need a bigger
string here's our little bunnies oh it
was strange so what are we doing today
Jess so today we are going to be doing
something that I'm pretty excited about
I just stupid so I got this magazine can
i order a lot of things from like 1-800
flowers or whatever they also have like
1-800 popcorn or something which it's
kind of crazy so I got this little
brochure they had these decorative
little Easter Egg popcorn things so I
thought I'm gonna get that for myself I
didn't realize that it was like a gift
set I just thought it was like an
inspirational idea I don't know what it
is you're gonna see popcorn decorating
kit can you decorate that kind of like a
gingerbread house but like no
gingerbread involved at all don't they
give us little candies little creams
this is the lower balls okay simple
instructions scissors and creativity is
all that's needed open the bat place
candy into small cups of water
Smarties hey careful I got to put this
in hot water to melt it's cute so now
what do we do I don't know did he really
give us that much stuff to work with
should I like bust out some stuff of my
own I am gonna use this though these are
some bright pink candy melts these will
look really nice on here I'm not gonna
need reading glasses I think these
edible cuz this looks like glue what's
in here you put plastic in the microwave
it will pack it see girls aren't gonna
look good on no that's gonna be a little
bit little bunny turns what's up in the
candy up alright
my knife is gotten less sharp taffy
shall we eat the candy this is a really
poor selection of decorating items do
something Appetit oh you bit the tip I
love decorate like give us candy that
looks good
silly you got a look at the picture it
looked so good well I'm gonna decorate
with this thing oh no I don't even know
where to begin
that's a hat very upsetting
what are these how do you get your egg
to stand up though so do you send these
as gifts of people you hate I think so
this is not fun I did not envision this
to be like this I'm nothing then okay
time oh that's why aren't you coming out
well the bad news is we have candy here
this is garbage I think more for
overnight shipping and then for this
stupid box of crap I'm very upset we
gotta figure this out no that was glue
tastes like my god this tastes good
don't I love Easter look at this how is
this supposed to come out of the tooth
that is so confused
this gum is candy this is not a gift
that you want to give to anyone what am
I gonna do with this oh this is good
tasting Wow hmm just don't waste this
Marty those are for eating this is all
licorice this is disgusting did this
turn into an eating video yeah but at
least we have like super festive shirts
yep being upset me too I was honestly
looking forward to this like it was the
only thing that I have been like wow I
can't wait to make this fun little
Easter treat with my sister Oh God like
you know something that like we would
have done when we were kids to reminisce
of our childhood these taste good though
here comes mr. Cottontail what is this I
don't know this is sad we're only on
ball on the one there's not gonna be a
ball number two no I'd like to do ball
number two really I mean honestly I'll
give them the fact that this was a
really really cute idea the extra maybe
we're just stupid
this is the worst selection of candy
that you could possibly want to put on
top of it and a popcorn ball so if you
have like an Easter party or something
you know friends and family over this
could be a really fun frustrating
holiday activity that you guys could
start to do together loving our
creativity okay cool
no I'm not done yet Oh God oh cool
Statue of Liberty oh my that doesn't
very nice that's cool
I need a mouth I'm done I am not done
yet
I'm disappointed like I feel so sad I'm
so into this well this is a Statue of
Liberty after Trump became president
yeah but you want to see mine look just
play well guys here's our eggs they look
good right okay but come on let's be
real look at this stuff that they gave
us to work with how are you supposed to
do anything this is the best one so
here's what we made this is a picture
from the website somewhere here on the
screen you we should use hot glue to eat
it this candy doesn't taste good this
was like chocolate
happy Easter all I did was eat this
whole video okay my teeth hurt Oh God my
teeth hurt yeah I think well guys I
think that's uh I think that does it for
our popcorn balls I'll actually put a
link in the description if you guys want
to get this for somebody I'm not sure if
I had recommended not sponsored clearly
because I think they'd be very upset
about video well that's it I hope that
you enjoyed our popcorn balls I'm pretty
sure this set some things might have
been missing but I will say the popcorn
balls are very very good they taste
really really good I'll put a link in
the description if you guys want to
check this out this is not sponsored I
just you know maybe you want to have as
much fun as we just had mmm
honey I'm choking on something we also
did a video on Jenna's channel I don't
know which one it's gonna be we've done
it we did a couple but we also did a
video on Jenna's channel so go check
that out and put a link in the
description somewhere next to the really
great link so that you could buy this
for your friends I think my our stuff
turned out a little bit better on my
channel but we don't know you because it
didn't happen we didn't do it it can't
be worse than turd face and turn topper
right over this bye
[Music]